kylie jenner is giving fans another peek
at baby number two baby number two
congratulations thank you the beauty
mogul shared some sweet snaps from her
family's lavish easter celebration
including this pic of her baby boy who
was born february 2nd in the arms of his
dad travis scott
while the photo doesn't show the little
one's face we do see his sense of style
rocking black and red sneakers and blue
jeans
safe to say the little man's got swag
now kylie has yet to share a full photo
of her son after announcing in march his
name will no longer be wolf which she
recently opened up to et about wolf was
never on our list okay um it just was
actually something
chloe suggested and i like don't do this
i liked the name i don't think anything
i still like
i
i just wasn't him but the reality star
says she and travis are steps closer to
deciding the new moniker
we have some really strong options but
we haven't officially changed we have
some placeholders so before i officially
change it i just want to be sure you're
seeing that little personality
but back to the easter fun
look what the easter bunny did
to say the kardashian jenner family went
all out for the holiday is an
understatement the festivities were held
at kris jenner's house and included
giant chocolate eggs with each family
member's name easter baskets and a table
filled with tasty treats well look at
these baskets for all of the grown-ups
oh my gosh
look at this
yeah kylie also gifted her daughter
stormi and niece's chicago true and
dream their very own gumball machines in
pink purple and baby blue i love it the
holiday get-together comes just days
after the family's new reality series
premiered on hulu my pregnancy was
really public this time i feel like
we're being chased
tristan and i are complicated
trust takes time
[Music]
and while fans will continue to get a
behind the scenes look into their lives
this time around some things might be a
little different i think for every
sister we have different boundary levels
and we all try to respect that your
boundaries are allowed to change and
mine will probably change later but i
think a lot of what is in the media is
sort of things that we feel we need to
film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives the episodes are
more a little bit documentary style and
i think that you have a real insight
into what the girls are doing not only
you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes and i
love that some of the journeys that all
of them are on it's just so interesting
to see it from the inside out and really
get a glimpse of what happens and how
they all balance what they do because
before you would see little snippets of
something and now i think the episodes
are um you know fuller of content that
shows the whole story never go against
the family
never go against the family
[Music]
you